SECURITY.
JASON.
>> Jason: JEFF, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
JOINING ME NOW IS TEXAS
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK.
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE WITH US.
FIRST AND FOREMOST, THERE WERE
TWO PEOPLE THAT LOST THEIR
LIVES, AND WE HAVE TO NOT SKIP
PAST THAT.
THOSE ARE FAMILIES THAT ARE
GRIEVING, A CHURCH AND A
COMMUNITY.
IT SHOULD HAVE NEVER HAPPENED.
GOD BLESS THOSE PEOPLE.
I HOPE WE CAN DO PROPER JUSTICE
TO THEIR MEMORY AND WISH THEM
GODSPEED.
>> YEAH.
JASON, LOOK, THERE WERE THREE
HEROES HERE.
RICHARD WHITE WAS PULLING HIS
PISTOL, ATTEMPTING TO TAKE DOWN
THE KILLER WHOSE NAME WE WON'T
MENTION.
AND TONY WALLACE WAS STANDING
THERE, DIDN'T HAVE A CHANCE TO
DEFEND HIMSELF AT ALL.
AND THEN JACK WILSON THAT YOU
SAW.
FOR PEOPLE WHO KNOW FIREARMS,
IT'S ONE THING TO GO TO THE
SHOOTING RANGE, JASON, AS MANY
OF US DO IN TEXAS AND OTHER
PLACES IN AMERICA, AND BE ABLE
TO FIRE A SHOT AT TEN OR
15 YARDS ON TARGET.
IT'S ANOTHER THING WHEN SOMEONE
IS POINTING A SHOTGUN THAT YOU
AND THE ADRENALINE IS FLOWING.
HE TOOK THAT AND IN SIX SECONDS
IT WAS OVER.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THIS COUNTRY LED BY THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE RADICAL LEFT
AND JOE BIDEN WHO HIGHLY
CRITICIZED OUR LAW ONLY PASSED
IT TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO CONCEAL
CARRY IN CHURCH, TO ALLOW
CHURCHES TO HAVE THEIR OWN
SECURITY FORCE.
WE PASSED THOSE TWO BILLS IN THE
LAST TWO YEARS IN TEXAS.
>> Jason: GOVERNOR, LET ME
JUMP IN.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
FIRST OF ALL, THE SHOT WAS
AMAZING.
COMES WITH MUSCLE MEMORY AND
GREAT TRAINING AND HAVING THE
GUTS TO DO IT AND BEING THE
RIGHT PERSON AT THE RIGHT TIME.
THE SECOND PART IS THE ABILITY
AND THE THOUGHT IN THE
PREPARATION THAT CHURCH HAD.
YOU ARE RIGHT.
JOE BIDEN TOOK A POSITION AND
WAS CHASTISING THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS FOR THIS.
WE HAVE THE SOUND OF THAT.
WATCH THIS.
>> IT'S IRRATIONAL, WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT TO THE GOVERNOR OF
TEXAS, IRRATIONAL WHAT THEY ARE
DOING.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT LISTENING
ACCESS TO HAVE GUNS, BE ABLE TO
TAKE THEM INTO PLACES OF
WORSHIP, STORE THEM IN SCHOOLS.
I MEAN, IT'S JUST ABSOLUTELY
IRRATIONAL.
>> Jason: GOVERNOR.
>> I HAVE A MESSAGE FOR
JOE BIDEN.
WE PASSED THAT BILL OUT OF THE
SENATE AND I AM PROUD OF IT.
SENATE BILL.
LET'S BE CLEAR TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT JOE BIDEN IS
DANGEROUS.
HE'S NOT JUST AN IDIOTIC PERSON
WHO SAYS IMPOSSIBLE, ABSURD
THINGS AND HE'S NOT JUST NAIVE
BUT HE'S DANGEROUS.
AMERICANS WHO HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
WHETHER YOU BELIEVE IN OWNING A
GUN OR NOT OWNING A GUN, THAT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE DANGEROUS.
IF THEY GET ELECTED TO THE
WHITE HOUSE, THEY WILL PASS
EXECUTIVE ORDERS TO TAKE YOUR
GUNS, TAKE YOUR ABILITY TO
PROTECT YOURSELF, YOUR FAMILY,
YOUR PROPERTY, AND YOUR FRIENDS
AS THOSE MEN DID YESTERDAY.
IT'S IDIOTIC TO SAY TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC THAT WE WANT TO
TAKE YOUR GUNS AND THAT'S GOING
TO MAKE PEOPLE BE BETTER.
THERE IS EVIL IN THIS WORLD,
JASON.
THERE IS DARKNESS AND THERE'S
LIGHT AND WE ALL KNOW IT AND
THAT WAS EVIL YESTERDAY.
FIRST RESPONDERS, GOD BLESS
THEM, THEY WERE THERE WITHIN A
MINUTE.
THIS WAS OVER IN SIX SECONDS AND
IF JACK WILSON HAD NOT TAKEN ON
THAT COLOR THERE COULD HAVE BEEN
TEN OR 15 PEOPLE KILLED BEFORE
THE POLICE GOT THERE.
IT'S THE CITIZENS RESPONSE THAT
THE MOST IMPORTANT TO STOP THE
SHOOTERS.
>> Jason: THAT'S RIGHT.
EXPLAIN TO THE VIEWERS AT HOME
WHAT WAS THOUGH THE TEXAS
CHANGED AND WHAT DID THAT CHURCH
DO IN PREPARATION?
WE'VE GOT A SHORT AMOUNT OF TIME
BUT EXPLAIN WHAT CHANGED AT THAT
CHURCH.
>> AFTER THE SUTHERLAND SHOOTING
AT THAT CHURCH, ASKED THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL KEN PAXTON
IF INDEED THE LAW ALLOWED US TO
CONCEAL CARRY AS IT WAS WRITTEN.
HE GAVE AN OPINION BACK TO US IN
THE SENATE AND SAID YES, IF THE
CHURCH ALLOWS IT TO.
THE CHURCH LIKE ANY OTHER
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONAL PRIVATE
BUSINESS COULD POST ASSIGNMENTS
THAT YOU CAN'T.
I'M NOT A FOUNDER CHURCH YET WHO
IS CLOSE TO THAT SIGN.
THEY MAY BE SOMEWHERE.
THEY KNOW THEIR MEN AND THEIR
WOMEN IN THEIR GOING TO BE WELL
TRAINED.
THEIR OWN SECURITY VOLUNTEER
TEAM.
SOME ARE OFF-DUTY POLICE
OFFICERS AND SHERIFFS DEPUTIES.
THEY ARE GOING TO PROTECT THEIR
CONGREGATION THEY ARE GOING TO
PROTECT PASTORS.
JASON, PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW
PASTORS PERSONALLY DON'T KNOW
HOW MANY THREATS THEY GET.
DON'T KNOW HOW MANY THREATS THEY
GET.
THIS PASTOR HAD BEEN THREATENED.
I TALK TO THEM LAST NIGHT.
THE PASTOR HAD BEEN THREATENED
BY THIS GUY BEFORE.
HE CAME IN DISGUISE.
THEY WERE WATCHING HIM.
BUT YOU KNOW YOU CAN'T PULL YOUR
GUN FIRST.
YOU HAVE TO REACT.
HE PULLED HER SHOTGUN OUT FROM
UNDER HIS COAT AND JACK WILSON
REACTED, AS DID RICHARD WHITE.
RICHARD WHITE WAS KILLED.
JACK WILSON TOOK HIM DOWN.
THAT'S ALLOWING CHANGE, YOU CAN
CARRY IF THE CHURCH ALLOWS IT.
>> Jason: JACK WILSON.
I CANNOT SAY ENOUGH GOOD THINGS
ABOUT ORDINARY PEOPLE WHO DO
EXTRAORDINARY THINGS.
GOD BLESS HIM.
HE SAVED A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT